[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace unas semanas os hablábamos de esa
especial relación que existe entre eeuu
y arabia saudita que ni siquiera el
mismísimo donald trump se atreve a
romper sin embargo hay algo que nos
dejamos en el tintero porque eeuu
importa petróleo de arabia saudita
no olvidéis que si sumamos los recursos
que hay en california texas y los nuevos
yacimientos que se han descubierto en
estados como dakota del norte el país
norteamericano es el tercer productor
mundial de crudo
sin embargo y a pesar de todo esto
todavía necesitan importar petróleo de
otros países y para más inri uno de
ellos es una de las mayores democracias
islámicas del mundo para que os hagáis
una idea arabia saudita es algo así como
el hollywood del radicalismo islámico es
el lugar donde nacieron terroristas como
osama bin-laden o donde se forjaron
ideologías como el salafismo que inspira
a montones de bandas terroristas en todo
el mundo
[Música]
en las calles de riad las mujeres tienen
que ir completamente tapadas y no pueden
ni siquiera a conducir y por supuesto
está terminantemente prohibido la
construcción de cualquier templo
religioso que no sea una mezquita e
incluso éstas tienen que estar sometidas
al control directo de los clérigos más
radicales que se aseguran de que no
entre por ningún resquicio el islam
moderado
y con todo este dinero que reciben de la
exportación de petróleo arabia saudita
se dedica a financiar grupos terroristas
como al-qaeda y mezquitas radicales en
todo el mundo sin embargo y pese a todo
esto tanto eeuu como el resto de países
del planeta se dedican a comprar
petróleo saudí a cascoporro como es esto
posible existe alguna razón geopolítica
que lo explique
hay alguna teoría de la conspiración hoy
vamos a responder a esta pregunta y
atentos porque hay una sorpresa para
todos vosotros al final del vídeo pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la historia del petróleo saudita por
sorprendente que parezca arabia saudita
es un país extremadamente joven hasta
principios del siglo 20 estaba bajo el
control del imperio otomano lo que ahora
es turquía sin embargo tras la primera
guerra mundial los otomanos desaparecen
del mapa y la península árabiga se
sumerge en un todos contra todos no
olvidéis que el desierto árabe es el
hogar de montones de tribus nómadas
capitaneadas por pequeñas monarcas
pero él
y finalmente en los años 30 una de estas
tribus nómadas capitaneada por una
familia real que se llamaba la familia
saud consigue imponerse sobre todas las
demás apoyada por sus amigos de gran
bretaña
por eso en 1932 es cuando nace en lo que
hoy conocemos como arabia saudita y por
cierto que en aquella época se trataba
de un país extremadamente pobre no
tenían ni carreteras ni coches ni luz
eléctrica ni mucho menos bancos y por
eso cualquier ayuda extranjera era más
que bienvenida
[Música]
sin embargo unos pocos años más tarde
una empresa estadounidense la standard
oil descubre yacimientos de petróleo y
como ya sabéis los que estáis suscritos
a visual politing desde hace tiempo el
petróleo saudí es especialmente
abundante y especialmente bueno está muy
cerquita de la superficie y es muy fácil
de refinar con lo cual basta con hacer
un pequeño agujero y punto chorros de
zumo de dinosaurio pero bueno he
esperado un momento porque no es tan
sencillo como parece extraer petróleo
requiere tecnología máquinas ingenieros
y mucho dinero precisamente todo lo que
faltaba en aquel momento en arabia
saudita como os podéis imaginar en un
país de nómadas no existe personal
cualificado ni bancos ni mucho menos
fondos de inversión
y por eso las petroleras estadounidenses
eran tan importantes para que los
saudíes pudieran convertir ese tesoro
que tenían bajo los pies en dinero
contante y sonante sin embargo los
saudíes no eran tontos no iban a
permitir que llegaran los
estadounidenses y se llevaran sus
recursos petroleros así por la cara y
por eso crearon una empresa la arabian
americana hoy compañía harán porque era
una 'joint venture' entre el gobierno
saudita y empresas norteamericanas como
te exámenes
[Música]
el petróleo saudita es el más barato de
extraer del mundo pensado en una cosa si
en texas en california encuentras un
yacimiento de petróleo primero necesitas
pedir permiso al propietario de la
tierra llegar a un acuerdo muy bien
comprarle los terrenos o alquilarse los
no olvidéis que en eeuu tienen una cosa
llamada propiedad privada y eso hace que
todo sea mucho más caro
[Música]
sin embargo en arabia saudita tienes
hectáreas de desierto que sólo
pertenecen a un señor el rey abdul que
por supuesto es uno de los socios de
aramco así que no importa el precio de
mercado del barril de petróleo los
márgenes del petróleo saudita siempre
van a ser los más altos del mundo
[Música]
y así es como empieza una bonita amistad
entre el gobierno americano y el
gobierno saudí aramco explota el
petróleo que está en el desierto después
este se refina en distintas plantas
muchas de las cuales están en suelo
americano mientras tanto el gobierno de
washington protege estos yacimientos
colocando bases militares
estadounidenses
y por supuesto en qué moneda cobran los
saudíes todo ese petróleo que venden
efectivamente en dólares estadounidenses
es decir que eeuu participa en la
explotación del petróleo participa en el
refino luego lo vende con los márgenes
de beneficio más altos del planeta y
además obtiene a cambio su propia divisa
vamos que todos son beneficios a cambio
los reyes saudíes se pegan una vida de
estrellas del rock
[Música]
si es verdad que en aquella época ya
eran unos fanáticos religiosos pero
estamos hablando de los años 40 50 y 60
y los malos de la película por estas
épocas no son los radicales islámicos
sino los comunistas y como os podéis
imaginar los saudíes con sus mezquitas
sus mansiones de lujo sus coches y sus
millones de petrodólares no se llevaban
precisamente bien con esos ateos
leninistas de la unión soviética pero
esperad un momento porque cuando las
cosas iban bien van y se tuercen en 1973
los saudíes se dan cuenta de que son los
dueños de prácticamente la mitad del
petróleo que se consume en todo el mundo
y que tienen los suficientes
petrodólares ahorrados como para imponer
sus condiciones de mercado
[Música]
y así es como surge la famosa crisis del
petróleo si queréis entender mejor lo
que ocurrió en este caso hacer clic en
el vídeo que vamos a poner al final pero
lo importante es cómo se solucionó esa
crisis del petróleo pues termina con que
la monarquía saudí nacionaliza aramco es
decir que ese enorme margen de
beneficios que obtenían por cada barril
de petróleo que vendían ya no lo quieren
compartir con eeuu lo quieren todo para
ellos y ahora os preguntaréis si eeuu ya
no gana dinero con el petróleo saudita
porque no sigue comprando ahora lo vamos
a ver
y la seguridad del suministro tras la
crisis del 73 el mundo entero aprendió
una lección muy importante si tu
economía depende del petróleo más te
vale no depender de un único proveedor
dicho de otra forma si es verdad que
eeuu tiene sus propios recursos
petrolíferos pero pueden agotarse o
incluso averiarse es decir imaginar por
ejemplo que un tornado destruye una
planta de extracción en texas o que un
gasoducto simplemente se rompe pensáis
que estas cosas no pueden ocurrir en un
país desarrollado pues os equivocáis
un oleoducto en canadá derrama 200.000
litros de petróleo en tierras aborígenes
si todo tu suministro de petróleo
depende de un único proveedor un
desastre como éste puede suponer que
todo tu país se quede sin gasolina
durante días semanas o incluso meses por
eso para evitar todos estos problemas
tanto eeuu como el resto de los países
diversificar el suministro concretamente
en este caso la mitad del petróleo que
consume eeuu viene de los propios
yacimientos que están en suelo americano
y que están explotados por empresas como
exxon mobil o chevron
pero la otra mitad se importa del
extranjero es decir que las empresas
estadounidenses negocian contratos con
empresas petroleras de otros países y en
contra de lo que podríais pensar
arabia saudita no es el principal
proveedor extranjero de eeuu el 40% del
petróleo que importan viene de canadá
más específicamente de los yacimientos
de la región de alberta las razones son
muy lógicas son dos países que están uno
al lado del otro y tienen muy buenas
relaciones diplomáticas y comerciales
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque a pesar
de todo esto arabia saudita sigue siendo
el segundo proveedor más importante y
porque os preguntaréis la primera razón
es que los saudíes en contra de lo que
pueda parecer son el país más estable a
la hora de suministrar petróleo
es decir si es cierto que ya nos han
demostrado que pueden cortar el
suministro por razones políticas pero
desde el punto de vista estrictamente
económico
arabia saudita es uno de los pocos
países del mundo que puede garantizar
que siempre producirá petróleo porque
tan sencillo como que tienen los
márgenes de beneficios más altos
por ejemplo esos yacimientos de petróleo
que hay en el mar del norte y que
pertenecen a gran bretaña son muy caros
de explotar necesita construir una isla
artificial en mitad del océano y hacer
un agujero super profundo
pero eso encarece muchísimo el coste de
extracción algo parecido ocurre en
canadá o venezuela donde el zumo de
dinosaurio aparece mezclado con la arena
y eso significa que es extremadamente
caro y complicado el refinar lo es decir
el convertir el crudo en un producto
útil para el consumo como pueda ser el
plástico la gasolina o el queroseno
sin embargo en el caso de graves o dita
basta con hacer una simple perforación y
chorros de petróleo de buena calidad y
muy barato de refinar y os preguntaréis
todo esto qué consecuencias tiene con la
continuidad del suministro
[Música]
pues muchas porque imaginad que el
precio de mercado del barril del
petróleo baja aquellos productores que
necesitan mucho dinero para extraerlo
van perdiendo cada vez más margen de
beneficio en muchos casos incluso pueden
llegar a obtener pérdidas recordáis ese
vídeo en el que hablábamos de venezuela'
en este país pese a que tienen ingentes
recursos de crudo han paralizado la
producción porque el barril sale tan
barato que ya no ganan dinero al
venderlo en realidad les sale más
rentable importar el crudo de otros
países como nigeria o incluso eeuu que
producirlo ellos mismos
no es porque no quieran a nicolás maduro
le encantaría que pedevesa la empresa de
petróleos de venezuela pudiera reabrir
sus plantas de extracción
[Música]
pero lo cierto es que perderían aún más
dinero porque el precio de mercado del
barril es tan barato que ya no hay
margen de beneficios sin embargo como
arabia saudita es el productor más
barato siempre van a tener beneficios y
por eso es uno de los pocos países que
nunca va a tener razones económicas para
dejar de exportar petróleo
[Música]
sin embargo esperado un momento porque
esta no es la única razón
petróleo ligero y petróleo pesado ni
todo el petróleo es igual ni todas las
plantas de refino están preparadas para
procesar el mismo tipo de crudo para
explicarlo de forma sencilla el zumo de
dinosaurio que sale de los yacimientos
de texas es muy líquido tan líquido que
los expertos lo llaman petróleo ligero
[Música]
y para poder convertir ese jugo de
dinosaurio en algo más sólido con lo que
podamos llenar los depósitos de nuestros
coches o fabricar objetos de plástico
necesitamos mezclarlo con otro tipo de
petróleo un poquito más espeso de otra
forma el proceso de refino podría salir
extremadamente caro así que lo más
barato que puede hacer una empresa de
refino como industrias koch o valero
energy es comprar barriles de petróleo
tejano y mezclarlos con barriles de
petróleo un poquito más espeso
bueno pues resulta que el petróleo
saudita es perfecto para hacer este
cóctel es más parte del negocio de las
petroleras estadounidenses consiste
precisamente en comprar crudo refinarlo
y después vender la gasolina el
queroseno o el plástico a distintas
empresas de distintos países y se trata
de un trabajo tan lucrativo como la
extracción pura y dura y por eso una
empresa como la shell que es de países
bajos donde en principio no hay ningún
yacimiento de petróleo es capaz de sacar
pingües benefícios con el oro negro
y eso explica que últimamente aramco
estoy haciendo ciertas operaciones
comerciales porque también quieren su
parte del pastel en este mercado
[Música]
entonces
aramco quiere reforzar su posición en el
golfo de méjico comprando una planta de
refinería en houston que está vendiendo
la empresa lion de al basel pero esperad
porque todavía hay mucho más si os
fijáis bien en la gráfica del coste de
extracción del petróleo veréis que irán
tienen los mismos márgenes de beneficio
que arabia saudita sin embargo casi
ningún país occidental compra petróleo
iraní queréis saber por qué puedes hacer
clic en este vídeo para descubrirlo
ahora la pregunta es os parece
sostenible permitir que arabia saudita
tenga tanto control sobre el mercado del
petróleo no creéis que sería bueno
diversificar aún más los ingresos y
permitir que entraran otros países en el
mercado del petróleo
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
y ahora es cuando viene la sorpresa
porque este mes de marzo voy a estar en
españa dando tres charlas me han
invitado a participar en una serie de
eventos que se llama el frame market
road show y concretamente voy a estar en
sevilla
santiago de compostela y gijón si
queréis acercaros encontrareis más
detalles en la descripción
por supuesto no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
m